what's up guys so I thought it'd be fun
to do something a little bit outside the
box today see in the past I did a
frequently asked questions video and
it's not like a Q&A where you send me
questions it really was just a way for
me to address a lot of questions that I
get frequently and I thought it'd be
time for a good update and to answer
each question I'm gonna kind of give you
a little skit along with it so I hope
you enjoy it question number one what
are some of your favorite foods hey hon
what are you making cheeseburger
you're making cheeseburgers oh my god
mmm can you make them the way I like
them you know like not how you usually
do it I mean like the Richard guy you
know my favorite cook the Top Chef guy
it makes them more like the cheese in
the middle and stuff and it's like just
so delectable and wonderful and I just
mmm
I'm gonna make whatever I'm gonna make
and you're gonna like it
so yes believe it or not my favorite
foods generally revolve around meat beef
I am a man and that's just how I am I
like hamburgers I like steak you know
chicken just like meaty things I'm a man
what can I say but do check out
Richard's channel he's a good chef
he has good recipes on there and had a
lot of fun watching his video so I put
an annotation for you to go check them
out we're going to season stuff
perfectly grill griddle face barbecue
fry smoke melt layer sauce and bump
the dude knows his stuff about food what
can I say and you know what I enjoy
cooking myself as well and so I kind of
relate to that question number two by
far is the question that I get asked the
most where do you get your posters
amazon.com I pretty much get all of them
off of amazon.com and you can search
just about any poster on there and they
will have it there all 11 by 17 if
you're wondering the size as well
question number three do you even lift
when I'm in the gym I like toys Hedgehog
shirts it gets all ladies talking
I used that kind of mockery question
that people ask a lot that honestly has
nothing to do with working out but a lot
of people actually do ask me if I like
to go to the gym and I am trying to get
in better shape I've lost about 15
pounds but I am trying to work out I try
to run a mile each night a week and I
have gained some muscle mass you can't
really tell it's there there's something
going on there nothing like my buddy the
flick pick yet but I'm working on it
he's a man the next question is what
type of camera do you use
well I use a Nikon d50 100 my best way
to show you this would be to show you in
the mirror it is an excellent camera and
the microphone setup I have is this rode
microphone here that allows my voice to
not sound horrible hopefully this is
actually working let's let's test it out
how does this sound I love my camera
it's terrific I can't even show you its
full quality here on YouTube just
because of load times and buffering and
all that stuff if I uploaded this video
100% quality first off it would take
like 10 hours to upload and you'd be
sitting there like watching 5 seconds of
it and then it would freeze another 5
seconds and it freezes it can but it's a
great camera and I definitely recommend
using it if you guys want to try to make
videos yourself now for my last question
I don't have a skit to go along with it
because it's really just a personal
question a lot of people have asked me
what got me into film criticism in
general and I thought I'd talk to you
guys about it so yeah I've always loved
movies I really honestly have my parents
showed me movies ever since I was a kid
and they brought me up watching all
different types of movies fun movies
like Star Wars and stuff when I got a
little bit older I started to view
movies a little bit more as artistic
pieces of work and not so much just
mindless entertainment but it got me to
a point where I was like you know what I
really like talking about movies and I
actually got to a point where I really
enjoyed making them too and I was making
some of the silliest short films with my
friends and I still have them all like
on VHS tape and everything and those are
some great times but getting into movies
and talking about movies it's like
seriously as an art form it just got to
a point where I loved examining movies
and it wasn't just like I had to examine
every movie I saw certain movies are
there just to watch and have fun but
those movies that come along where
you're like they really make you think
and they want you to learn more about
filmmaking and they want you to actually
think more
out how the film was made and if it has
hidden meanings and things like that I
really got into that when I started
doing videos on YouTube in 2009 it was
just for fun and it still is just for
fun and I honestly don't take myself too
seriously I really am just a happy kid
with a camera I hope that you guys
continue to enjoy watching the videos I
wanted to do this just for fun to give
you guys a little insight into some of
the things you've wondered I hope I'll
be back pretty soon this week with a
review for Jack the giant slayer and 21
and over and as always guys if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck my eyes